when it comes to the crucifixion of
Jesus actually it's a lot of people
misquote what the Quran actually says um
and they just focus on the fact that we
don't believe he was killed or crucified
um but what the Quran actually says word
for word is they they meaning the Romans
and Jews and people they did not kill
him nor did they crucify him but it was
made to appear that way so let me kind
of paint the picture because context is
very important you have Jesus right just
like Moses went to his people and it
literally split the sea for them Jesus
came he healed he's like you're blind
let me heal you you have leprosy let me
heal you this water I will walk on it
this water I will turn into wine there's
no explanation other than this person is
a prophet of God and telling the truth
and we need to listen to them they still
do not listen though these are clearly
very disobedient and and you know
defiant people just like unfortunately
the children of Israel had a history of
being very defiant
um and I don't need to mention the uh
the numerous times where that's recorded
in the Quran and in the Old Testament so
these people very clearly knew he was a
prophet but still wanted to kill him
they still wanted to go out of their way
and get rid of him so God you can maybe
look at it as a punishment let them
think that they succeeded in it because
Allah God leaves astray those who don't
want to be guarded he gives them the
message they reject it enough times God
said okay fine you want to be you want
to be left to straight go go astray so
they thought
he was crucified
um but he wasn't and what happened is
very actually interesting I'll send you
guys a video that highlights this but in
Psalm 91 it speaks about Jesus and this
is confirming a new testament being
protected by God so his enemies will not
beat him and he will be raised up to
heaven by the Angels the angels will
take him up to heaven right this is
prophecy about Jesus and what happened
in the kind of you know Christian
theology is that he was killed so how
was he protected and taken up by Angels
if he ended up being killed that doesn't
add up the Quran came down and said that
the Angels took Jesus up peace and
blessings be upon him and protected him
so that he can come back which we
believe he's going to come back as well
for the second coming and kill the
Antichrist and all of that so very
interesting because now you're going to
be saying
relax that's wrong with you you're crazy
you're so ahistorical I want to slap you
but hear me out hear me out the Quran
says that it was made to appear that way
so what the people think that back then
is that Jesus was crucified so that is
without a doubt what they are going to
say but I will mention is it completely
100 a historical to say that there are
people that believed he was not
crucified that's not true there was a
second century Church Father named
bacilities who people said that he
claimed to have a secret tradition he
believed and this is written in the book
of heresies um by um I forget who wrote
it that Jesus was switched out on the
cross with Simon and that and we believe
that that Simon not Simon but we believe
that which Simon Simon Peter or the
second Simon like I'm I'm not sure which
Simon says not that it matters just in
case you know okay yeah yeah so this
erroneous claimed that um facilities
claim that Simon has switched out with
uh with Jesus on the cross and some
people some Scholars say that what
happened is God replaced Jesus with one
of the disciples or with another person
and made him look like Jesus Jesus so
that people would think it was a kind of
other punishment so there's actually a
second century person who believed who
is a church father who believed that
Jesus was not crucified and you have
people like the abianites and and I
think the monarchites or something like
that who believe that Jesus was not God
but a prophet and a messenger like
Muslims believe so all I'm gonna say is
that judeo-christian history including
the time of Jesus is not something that
is certain or factual Simon of Cyrene um
the Warner says thank you brother Habibi
but um so all I'm trying to say is that
it is not something that is clear-cut
especially historically
um and it is definitely something to be
investigated and does not invalidate the
Quran kind of based on what is said uh
does that make sense I know I said a lot
do you have any uh any questions about
that that makes sense I mean it's
definitely like that that's probably the
biggest difference in the religions no
because it's funny no no so so wait wait
I want to recap and make sure I
understand what you're saying okay so my
story is they put Jesus up on the cross
the disciples who were not in hiding at
that point
um including his mother and Mary
Magdalene they were they and and many
others were there
watched him die buried him in the tomb
which they didn't always give that that
give that even much courtesy to people
that were crucified but they did they
let him be buried in a tomb three days
later Mary Magdalene was the first one
to see him she came he came out and he
was like Hey I'm not dead hey you know
God brought me back to life and I'm
resurrected and which is an example of
what will happen to all of us if we if
we you know believe and we you know
succumb to God's Will and that then then
there were hundreds and hundreds of
eyewitnesses to his resurrection and the
story spread like wildfire after that
and it was already a fire and it went
nuts okay that's my story yours what I'm
hearing is they switched them out they
put somebody else on one of the Apostles
and the people that were there
witnessing Jesus's crucifixion
actually were tricked by God because God
made him this other person look like
Jesus and then three days later Jesus
just like popped out from behind a tree
and was like you know like what happened
like I'm exaggerating I'm making light
of it but you know it it doesn't like
the part that God why would God trick
someone into that's it's over
complicating the story it's it seems
than than what it you know my story is
hard enough to believe so and just just
to make sure we're on the same page
before Rami carries on the theological I
guess significance of the biblical
narrative is that this is the original
sin yes
mm-hmm that he he that he dies in order
that all of our sins might be forgiven
yes to part to cleanse all of his
followers of sin it's not like the most
important part of the whole religion
it's like the base of it I mean no Jesus
dying on the cross so like that's a
massive difference like in the two
religions like it's a big deal yeah so I
just wanted to outline that to the
viewers too because people are like
where you guys going with this this is
the main eulogical significance of the
crucifixion that they believe yeah 100
so when this is why well first I want to
mention we don't believe Jesus came back
three days later we don't believe he he
appeared ever
um you know since then we do believe in
the second coming and the Antichrist and
all that obviously that hasn't happened
yet but we do believe that will happen
um the reason I mentioned the condyla
context is because it obviously it
sounds bad if God like just tricks
people
um but like I mentioned God is not just
tricking innocent people this is he's he
sent them a messenger who from our
perspective spoke as a baby he'll build
the Blind and the lepers walked on on
Waters recorded in the Bible you know
did all these Miracles and they still
rejected him so God let them go further
into misguidance um that's basically it
but at the same time you still have
remnants in even what we have today in
the Bible of Jesus and like for example
Psalm 91 like I mentioned saying that
basically he will not be crucified for
lack of a better term you still have
Jesus himself kind of uh saying that
there's one God and not claiming to be
God and all of that stuff
um but I I do I want to ask you a
question now
um you mentioned there were hundreds of
eyewitnesses now my question is were
there hundreds of reports or where would
were there basically was there one
report that mentioned hundreds of
eyewitnesses there there were many
reports I can't give you a number I can
come back on our next talk and give you
and give you more actual I I'll give you
more I'll do more research and give some
more data from um you know the
theologians and historians who have
studied this for 2000 years now and I'll
be happy to but you know go back to you
know when he from when he was arrested
and he he went through you know a full
day of torture and lashings and carrying
across through this town before he was
ultimately hung on the cross and you
know so for me to so whether or not you
someone would believe that he he
resurrected there really is very little
historical dispute that he went through
that process and he suffered
tremendously
um you know the thorn the crown of
thorns the lashings with the the whip
that had you know fragments of bone and
nail you know woven into it that his
back was raw and he many people died
just from the beating he took before he
even got up on the cross so there's a
lot there is eyewitness and historical
documentation around that mostly Lee
from Apostles and theologians but also
from some there was a guy named Josephus
who was like a historian at the time who
was not a religious figure and he mostly
reported on political stuff and you know
he he talks about Jesus a little bit in
there so there's so much there that says
that it was him and it did happen and I
I for me it's a it's a bigger leap that
God would try to further fool the people
that were doing that to him because I
think what happened after that is many
of those people came to repent and turn
to God after the resurrection after
Jesus's death and at the resurrection
because they said now they're like oh my
god what have I done and I think that
that is more powerful for them so I and
and I'm just not sure what the
motivation is for changing that story I
other than to
undermine the resurrection yeah what if
it wasn't changing the story but I
actually clarifying a misunderstanding
if it was that no that's a good point uh
and but but it doesn't it feels like
it's unclarifying it and I feel it feels
muddier than than the original story all
right make sure you guys like subscribe
and if you're interested in learning how
to dominate social media and make money
online I'm having a crazy sale with my
Online Academy where I teach you all my
strategies how I've hit over a hundred
thousand Subs in four months how I've
generated five million dollars using
organic marketing so DM me bank if you
guys want to learn more about that
gone
[Music]
[Music]